l'une des premières choses que l'on fait
lorsqu'on s'intéresse aux plantes aux
champignons aux fleurs c'est d'apprendre
leur nom mais quand il est question des
lichens même cette première étape est
parfois difficile à franchir
parce que beaucoup n'ont jamais été
identifiés heureusement des passionnés
veille à faire avancer les connaissances
sur ces organismes méconnu
[Musique]
sur les bords de nos routes vivent des
êtres préhistoriques des pionniers de la
vie terrestre
parmi les tous premiers êtres vivants
qui ont réussi à coloniser les
continents il y as 400 millions d'années
les lichens
un lichen pour résumer c'est un
champignon qui abrite en lui une algue
voici les entrailles d'un week end
vue au microscope les boules vertes
celles algues les tubes c'est le
champignon le champignon enveloppe
l'algue il l'a nourrie pour qu'elles
nourrissent à son tour comme s'il
faisait de l'élevage grâce à sa couche
supérieure le champignon protège la
langue de la sécheresse et des trop fort
rayons du soleil
ils lui offrent les minéraux qu'ils
recueillent dans l'air dans l'eau et
dans le substrat auquel il est attaché
ils contrôlent la croissance de l'algue
pour ne pas qu'elle devienne trop
envahissante
en retour la ligue lui fournit les
sucres de la photosynthèse
les lichens sont pratiquement partout
surtout là où les plantes ne peuvent
survivre
on a montré que certaines espèces
pouvait endurer un froid de moins 196
degrés dans les pires des airs aussi il
y a des lichens certains résistent à une
chaleur de 90 degrés ou peuvent perdre
99% de l'euro et survivre ainsi pendant
toute une année
on a même déjà lâché des lichens dans
l'espace ils ont résisté au vide
et au rayon mortels
sur la terre il y a vingt mille espèces
de lichens connu plus probablement des
milliers d'autres encore à découvrir un
monde multiforme multicolore est
fascinant c'est à ce monde que
s'intéresse jean gagnon biologistes dans
sa vie professionnelle il répertorie les
mousses et des lichens pour le ministère
des forêts de la faune et des parcs du
québec notamment dans le grand nord et
dans ses vacances comme aujourd'hui
eh bien il va encore examiner des
lichens c'est intéressant partout j'aime
beaucoup la couleur des lichens dans les
tropiques mais au québec on a aussi de
très beaux week-ends notamment un
article le long du saint-laurent en
forêt boréale forêt décès dûs ils sont
partout
cette semaine il est en gaspésie avec
quelques autres passionnés comme lui
parmi eux un vétérinaire
tom phillips il vient d'albany dans
l'état de new york
j'ai des microscopes et un petit
laboratoire chez moi
juste ce qu'il faut pour identifier les
espèces à nice elle vient de nouvelle
écosse c'est une biologiste à la
retraite elle est plutôt spécialiste des
mousses même bien aussi se pencher sur
les lichens
j'aime plonger dans les petites choses
ça demande de la patience pour aller
voir les détails qui caractérise les
espèces quant à francis anderson autre
néo écossaise à la retraite c'est une
ancienne bibliothécaire
quand j'ai voulu en apprendre davantage
sur les dickens je me suis aperçu qu'il
n'y avait pas de guide terrain alors
j'ai décidé d'en écrire à son guide
destiné aux débutants contient la
description de 138 espèces françois
sanderson est aujourd'hui unique et nos
l'ogre reconnu je suis constamment à la
recherche de lichens
chaque année je viens en voir au québec
j'ai été quatre ans étudier les lichens
du parc du bic et j'ai découvert là une
espèce nouvelle pour la science
[Musique]
pour s'extasier ces gens là n'ont pas
besoin de marcher des kilomètres ou
grimper des montagnes leur plaisir est à
portée de loups la gaspésie est riche en
lichens les bords de mer par exemple la
moindre tache sur les pierres et le
lichen ou plusieurs lichens les oranges
et on voit au moins quatre espèces is
only kane du genre cale au placard et on
a trois espèces genre cantoria on a
aussi dans les blancs au moins trois
espèces et on a aussi tout au travers
quelques espèces de lichens
microscopique incrustés au substrat ici
dans les cannes aura notamment
et si on fouille encore avons trouvé
d'autres et si on a le réseau capon
géographie comme parce que ça ressemble
à des cartes de pays
le bolloc'h pulmonaire ya dont la forme
imitent les poumons
d'où son nom latin le monde des lichens
et véritablement complexe chaque lichens
est un écosystème en soit certains
abritent même une scie à nos bactéries
cet organisme connu pour infester les
plans d'eau identifier les lichens n'est
pas une mince affaire
souvent il faut utiliser la chimie pour
s'y retrouver
je crois que ses fils ya sesia ufficiale
doumbia il faudrait que je l'emmène au
labo pour faire un test chimique
certains tests peuvent se faire sur
place regardez par exemple ce qui se
passe quand on met quelques gouttes
d'une solution de potasse sur ce
week-end
cette caractéristique des lichens est
utilisé en chimie depuis des siècles le
fameux papier tournesol qui sert à
évaluer l'acidité d'un liquide est fait
à base de poudre de lichens
les lichens sont des experts en chimie
île secrète des centaines de composés
unique qui ne se retrouve nulle part
ailleurs sur la terre on s'en sert en
teinture riz en parfumerie et en
pharmacie
les antibiotiques du futur viendront
peut-être des lichens ce sont aussi de
bons indicateurs de la pollution ils y
sont très sensibles parce qu'ils se
nourrissent de l'humidité de l'air grâce
aux lichens on peut suivre l'évolution
de la qualité de l'air dans les villes
par exemple il ya une étude récente qui
a été fait pour la ville de québec où on
visitait des données d'il ya une
trentaine d'années sur la présence
absence de lichens et on voit une nette
amélioration à québec c'est à dire une
plus grande diversité de lichens en
ville cambre hâtivement il ya 30 ans
le monde des lichens est encore très
mystérieux pour la science on est loin
de connaître toutes les espèces dans ses
sorties
jean gagnon fait souvent des découvertes
on parle d'eux
nouvelle espèce au niveau régional au
niveau provincial aussi quelques espèces
nouvelle pour le canada et pour
l'amérique du nord
il ya aussi quelques espèces nouvelles
pour la science que j'ai trouvé un
article une espèce qui va être publiée
bientôt dans une revue britannique en
forêt aussi il y a des lichens sur cet
arbre tombé au sol par exemple est une
particularité sur ce tronc sequana aussi
des lichens qu'on verrait pon
généralement sur des troncs d'arbres
c'est que le tronc d'arbre est tombé
sans doute depuis une vingtaine d'années
est une tout autre flore apparaît certes
un lichen pente aux branches la moindre
tache sur les troncs et probablement un
lichen la poudre blanche qui recouvre
pratiquement tout le tronc de ce grand
thuya est un lichen peut-être même deux
lichens you lichens minuscule qu'on
appelle tête d'épinglé qui recouvre tout
les touts les sillons ici là on le voit
partout je vois en fait une tige
minuscule sait même pas de l'ordre du
millimètre et au bout il ya une petite
boule qui est en fait les frais de
situation
dans l'ère be louis-marie de
l'université laval toute une section est
consacrée aux lichens plusieurs
centaines d'espèces
c'est du réseau cap ont un genre très
fréquent en arctique et c'est un
spécimen qui provient du parc tour sur
youtube que revient à l'eau claire
jean gagnon a déjà récolté plus de
quinze mille spécimens mais seulement la
moitié ont été identifiés et classé
jusqu'ici le gros du travail non lic
hainaut log se fait en laboratoire avec
un microscope jeu un lichen qui est
incrusté à une roche un week-end qu'on
dit crustacés pour le récolter faut
ramener aussi la roche pas juste les
week-ends pour savoir à quelle espèce on
a à faire il faut aller voir par exemple
la forme des spores contenues dans les
minuscules fructification qu'on appelle
des appeaux taissy l'identification des
lichens et si ardu que jean gagnon lui
même doit souvent faire appel à une
personne encore plus spécialisés que lui
ces boîtes recèle peut-être des trésors
des espèces nouvelles pour la science
mais pour les identifier il faudra des
années de travail
c'est le cas pour beaucoup n'ont pas été
identifiés et c'est comme des spécimens
d'archivés qui vont l'être un jour mais
sans doute pas par moi
[Musique]
- une autre génération de chercheurs se
penchera donc sur les spécimens récoltés
par jean gagnon mais qu'est ce qu'une
génération d'humains à côte et d'être
âgé de plus de 400 millions d'années
[Musique]